das vor wenigen stunden also wenn
irgendjemand gedacht hat hier in der
kriegs hauptstadt der greift die
russische armee derzeit nicht mehr an
dann ist das der brutale gegenbeweis
gewaltiger anschlag dort
raketeneinschlag von putins raketen sie
sind also zurück dort in der kriegs
hauptstadt ja das ist eine
machtdemonstration putins denn diese
raketen die haben eingeschlagen als der
un-generalsekretär gerade zu besuch in
kiew war hier sehen wir ihn weil sie
lenski beim ukrainischen präsidenten das
ist kein zufall putin schlägt zu wenn
der chef der vereinten nationen dort ist
diese rakete sie galt kiew sie galt den
vereinten nationen sie galt damals der
ganzen welt ja und darüber als auch er
ja noch gesprochen danach nach diesem
besuch der präsident der ukraine motto
mir selenz gehören wir einmal dabei
schießt die rakete oder der ukraine
russische raketen angriffe auf die
ukraine in kiew odessa und anderen
städten beweisen einmal mehr dass wir
unsere wachsamkeit nicht aufgeben dürfen
wir sollten nicht glauben dass der krieg
vorbei ist wir müssen weiterkämpfen und
die besatzer vertreiben heute hat die
russische armee ihre offensive im osten
unseres landes im dom bass fortgesetzt
und versucht in den südlichen regionen
voran zu kommen unsere streitkräfte
werden die eindringlinge ab und ich bin
jedem unsere verteidiger dankbar der
dabei hilft wir tun alles um unsere ami
zu helfen und sie mit allen notwendigen
waffen zu versorgen
und wir schauen direkt in die ukraine zu
unseren kollegen philipp iad auf dort in
greven das ist die heimatstadt von
präsident selensky diese rakete jetzt
wieder auf die hauptstadt obwohl sich
die ganze welt vor allem aber auch die
menschen in kiew darauf eingestellt
hatten hier ist es doch jetzt wieder
ruhig das war kaum zu glauben diese mega
explosion dann doch
ja absolut die menschen hatten sich
daran gewöhnt dass es wieder ruhig ist
aber ich glaube nicht dass sie
überrascht waren nach allem was sie
davor erlebt haben nach allem was sie
auch gesehen haben in den vororten
butter enterbt ihn war klar dass wir
schieben das russische riesigen kann
jederzeit wieder zuschlagen der
bürgermeister von kiew vitali klitschko
hatte ja auch immer wieder gewarnt
achtung kehrt noch nicht nachgibt ist
noch nicht sicher ich glaube das ist der
beste weiß dass er recht hatte solange
putin diesen krieg führt so lange ist
keine einzige stadt in der ukraine prix
sicher wir sind in einer nochmal neuen
phase in diesem krieg philipp alles hat
sich verlagert abseits dieser gewaltigen
explosion jetzt in kiew in den don was
in die ost ukraine schlachtung mario
pohl schlacht um die ost ukraine und
gleichzeitig gewaltige waffenlieferungen
neue zusagen auch aus den usa wir hören
noch mal rein was der us präsident joe
biden in den vergangenen stunden gesagt
also wir greifen nicht russland an
sondern wir stärken wir unterstützen die
ukraine das zeigt ja wie schwierig das
ist im moment diese balance zu finden
philipp einerseits
russland klar zu machen dass das kein
direkter krieg mit russland ist offenbar
ist das ja auch den usa weiter ganz ganz
wichtig und gleichzeitig massive
unterstützung für die ukraine
absolut ich glaube das muss man russland
auch gar nicht wirklich klar machen denn
der kreml war steht das ja ich glaube
die menschen die im kreml sitzen
vladimir putin und seine umgebung
verstehen durchaus dass der westen jetzt
nicht vorhat russland anzugreifen es ist
natürlich die ihre propaganda
maschinerie die aus jeder westlichen
unterstützung einen unmittelbaren
angriff auf mich in russland macht
dagegen kann man am besten auch nicht
viel ausrichten die propaganda in
russland arbeitet 24 7 und wenn die
einen kriegs vorwand braucht und dann
werden sie sich ausdenken genauso wie es
sie auch mit der ukraine getan haben
deswegen dieser versuch russland nicht
zu provozieren der kann nicht
funktionieren
russland hat sich eine ganz eigene
realität gebaut die nach eigenen regeln
funktioniert und auf die haben wir
schlichtweg keinen einfluss findet er
hat eine ganz besondere frau getroffen
die der ihre geschichte erzählt hat was
lana wir wollen sich hier einmal zeigen
fotos von ihr die du mitgebracht hast
von ihr und ihren drei kleinen kindern
es ist eine kriegsgeschichte dennis
langer hier kümmert sich alleine um die
kinder sie hat ein foto von ihrem denn
der der steckt fest der kommt nicht raus
der ist in einer schier ausweglosen
situationen das letzte foto das er ihr
aufs handy geschickt hat das kam dort
unten aus den bunkern unter dem
stahlwerk in mario pohl lasst uns rein
schon in das was dir diese frau zu
berichten hat lasst uns rein schauen in
dieses stahlwerk in dem so viele
menschen in dieser verzweifelten lage
weiter ausharren und putins einziger
plan ist sie aussuchen
die hafenstadt mario pohl sie ist
vergangenheit nach zwei monaten nichts
übrig und doch mittendrin menschen
tausende menschen hier im stahlwerk
azoff stahel mario pohl auf diesem
unwirklichen gelände hier sind sie die
letzten menschen von mario pohl frauen
und noch immer kinder und die letzten
kämpfer ausgehungert in den katakomben
des stahlwerks sie haben nur ein ziel
irgendwie überleben irgendwie sie sind
eingekesselt durch die russischen
truppen seit wochen
abgeschnitten von der welt fast denn
bild trifft wetzlarer aus mario pohl
eine junge mutter mit ihren kindern
ihr mann ist im stahlwerk abgeschnitten
eingekesselt
in offstein sind mehr als 2000 menschen
in einem bunker aus drei ebenen
auf jeder ebene sind sehr viele menschen
die
militärs sind getrennt von den frauen
und den kindern es gibt sogar säuglinge
es sind sehr viele verletzte zivile und
soldaten die stimmung ist kämpferisch
aber die vorräte gehen zu ende deswegen
warten sie auf unterstützung
sie müssen dort herausgeholt werden sie
brauchen hilfe
entweder
diplomatisch oder mit dem militär aber
sie müssen irgendwie dort herausgeholt
werden während draußen der frühling
kommt und die kinder auf dem trampolin
spielen sind die gedanken immer bei papa
er sich an sein leben klammert im
stahlwerk von mario pohl
eine winzige hoffnung dieses handy wann
kommt die nächste nachricht von ihm gibt
es doch noch hoffnung wird er irgendwann
sagen können ich bin da raus raus aus
der hölle wir sagen denen dass wir alles
tun werden um sie aus dem bunker
rauszuholen dass sie die hoffnung und
den glauben nicht verlieren sollen dass
sie weiter glauben sollen dass sie auf
jeden fall gerettet werden
wir hoffen auf die unterstützung der
ganzen welt dass der frieden wieder
kommt dass uns geholfen wird
wir wünschen uns
so schnell wie möglich frieden wohl sein
und ruhe
[Musik]
reporter von dem dieser eindringlich
emotionale bericht stand weiter bei uns
zugeschaltet aus der ukraine findet wie
hält dieses ehepaar überhaupt kontakt er
gefangenen unter der erde in den bunkern
dieses stahlwerk sie draußen mit den
kindern im kriegsgebiet
ja kontakt halten ist wirklich das
schwierigste gerade das war so das war
dem der ehemann von bislang zunächst als
angehöriger oder als soldat der
ukrainischen küstenwache im hafen von
mario pohl gekämpft hat dann brach die
verbindung für zwölf tage ab und islam
wusste nicht ob bei dem auch noch am
leben ist wo er ist wie es ihm geht dann
kam das erste lebenszeichen der sms bzw
über einen der vielen messenger die hier
in der ukraine benutzt werden wie
telegramm und weimar er hat sich
gemeldet und hat einfach nur die
nachricht geschrieben ich bin immer so
stahlwerk ich bleibe
und das gelang erst mal optimistisch man
kennt das alles auch stahlwerk und weiß
dass dort unterirdische bunkeranlagen
sind für uns darauf verstand war dem
allerdings dass er und seine kameraden
sich in der absoluten falle befinden und
hat auch genau das geschrieben ich weiß
nicht wie es weitergeht offenbar stecken
fest wir schauen noch ein leben wir
schauen wir mal wieder ganz kurz weil du
es gerade ansprichst die katakomben
dieses stahlwerks in diese stahlwerk
rein auf eine grafik die ein bisschen
einmal veranschaulicht wie das dort
aussehen könnte dort unten in diesen
bunkeranlagen also viele etagen
übereinander zwischendrin überall
soldaten und zivilisten nach wie vor
auch frauen und kinder die da gefangen
sind du hast das ganze gerade viele eine
falle wird als falle bezeichnet dort
unten also es gibt logischerweise kein
tageslicht mehr es gibt dort auch
natürlich nicht ständig irgendwas zu
essen ich ständig nachschub sondern man
es wirklich abgeschnitten mittlerweile
seit wochen dort unten sah kurz einmal
was wollen die menschen was wollen die
soldaten dort eigentlich also die wollen
ja nicht aufgeben die wollen ja nicht
raus marschieren umringt von russischen
truppen dann in gefangenschaft gehen
oder nach russland gekarrt werden was
ist deren dringlichste wunsch im moment
die wollen irgendwie evakuiert werden
dann in gefangenschaft würde würde für
viele von ihnen einfach heißen dass sie
misshandelt gefoltert und vermutlich
auch getötet werden nachdem was russland
mit mario pohl gemacht hat wird es bei
den ukrainischen soldaten keine gnade
walten lassen das heißt sie wollen
entweder ist eine evakuierung aufzugeben
wege erreicht wird auf diplomatischen
wege das heißt dass ich einen drittstaat
beispielsweise deutschland bereit
erklärt eine art evakuierungs mission zu
machen natürlich eine absprache mit
russland und es schafft alle menschen
herauszuholen zivilisten oder soldaten
die andere alternative ist das keine so
mit waffen ausgestattet wird dass sie in
der lage ist mario pohl zu kämpfen ganz
egal aus welcher nicht nur aber das ist
natürlich es ist nicht realistisch so
muss man das leider sagen so kann man es
nicht sagen wenn man sich gerade mit
bislang unterhält die in tag dafür betet
dass ihr mann frei kommt aber es ist
natürlich nicht realistisch dem putin
hat keinerlei interesse daran diese
männer zu lassen jedoch keinerlei
interesse daran die zivilisten
freizulassen auch vollständig von
orientiere korridoren spricht aber den
ganzen punkt ist ja länger zivilisten
dort ausharren desto weniger nahrung
haben auch die soldaten desto knapper
wird für sie die zeit das heißt je mehr
menschen im stahlwerk bin desto besser
ist es für putin dessen einziges ziel es
ist diesen menschen irgendwie zum
aufgeben zu bewegen und ja natürlich sie
sagen alle wir bleiben bis zum letzten
wir werden bis zum letzten kämpfen aber
irgendwann man kann man nicht mehr
kämpfen wenn man so ausgewogenheit ist
wenn man so wenig wasser hat wenn man so
wenig nahrung hat dass man einfach keine
kraft zum kämpfen findet um das weiß
natürlich dass also die brutale
strategie von vladimir putin werden
tausende menschen dort in einem
stahlwerk weiter ausharren